permanence is in theaters this Friday
about a a family in 1982 small-town
Virginia centers around a 13 year old
girl and her parents going through some
struggles and their dad of the film
Rainn Wilson here on the rich Johnson
show you're playing dad's now man I'm
damned I've crossed over how many
fathers have you played in your career
this is two now okay it's just that's it
two two dads what the hell yeah I
crossed 50 you know it happened is that
right well yeah maybe maybe I'm just
look your your career is going great you
don't need me to help you out maybe you
play yourself as my two dads and you
reboot that that seriously I love it
what do you think of that I love it my
two dads part to perfect and you just
play your yourself yeah yep maybe you
could play the kid too
and some sort of CGI bizarreness what do
you think a play every character in the
show just a one-person show well well it
guinness bran thanks for coming on okay
I've got my career let's go let's go
pitch that what do you think of your
Seahawks right now yeah I don't know
we're just going over the on the break
over the injuries there I mean this
really hurts them if I mean they have to
beat the Rams it's must-win and even
then do they get in a wild card if they
beat the Rams they beat the Rams if they
beat the Rams they'll be in a great spot
to win the entire NFC West they sweep
the season series from LA they'd be tied
with them in record-wise but can't be in
first place with trips to Dallas with
Ezekiel Elliott returning and then the
Arizona Cardinals it'll be fun
I know defense is so depleted I mean
Sherman and Averell and Chancellor gone
and now Bobby Wagner is that right yeah
no KJ right yeah Bobby right hamstring
Pete Carroll said he'll know later in
the week but it's not looking good KJ
right concussion hmm well Bobby how
about it look I might actually why I
might have to go play defense what do
you think can you can you put a
linebacker is that right yeah what would
your mentality be out there just run
just run just run very good run around
runner it's like Russell Wilson put the
bunny yeah the Russell Wilson is
offensively it's amazing watching him
play yeah and that's why you know I
understand Sherman being out kam
chancellor being out able be it out KJ
right being out it's
it's unbelievable but Wagner losing him
that would be the coup de Gras I think
but then there's still Russell Wilson
running around like like Magners like
three players in one he really is and
yeah Wilson may be an MVP year but I
need to see them go to the playoffs for
that to happen he's incredible though I
mean it must be incredible tell me cuz
I'm a guy's conferring for the Jets what
is it like to have a quarterback well
mountains been pretty proud gosh but
it's like at least with Russell you know
that there's still 10 years later the
player set the exciting thing is a play
is never over you know with other teams
the defensive line overwhelms and swarms
the offensive line and you're kind of
like you can go back to your phone and
text someone or eat some popcorn or
something with the Seahawks that's just
the beginning
that's the beginning of the action is
when five guys are about to pounce on it
right and Ben Roethlisberger's kind of
the same way where the play begins after
he said usually when a quarterback is
hit the play is over right but when
you're hit the play actually begins who
was on your fantasy teams this year
right well you had to bring that up
didn't you I did it was a it was a sad
weekend I'm in the fifth place
consolation play-off round because last
week I had my the name of my team I was
very proud of Love Hurts Love Hurts yes
can I sing that without paying rights
they just did yes we'll stick you with
her but I lost hurts and mix into
concussions and then I put I had arts to
start because they said he was gonna
start and then an hour before they
pulled him but I was taking my family to
go see Hamilton so I didn't get to show
up him out so you don't have a rule in
your fantasy league that if you're
taking your children to Hamilton and
somebody who was active becomes inactive
there's no Hamilton as you know Hamilton
trap door I need to talk to the
commissioner again give me that give me
our Commissioner on the commissioner
Manuel Miranda says it's okay yeah you
know if only yeah so it was an OK season
it was it was tough yeah yeah so you're
done but you're in the consolation prize
to pay the least amount of money is that
the law right I don't know what happens
if you win fifth place if I somehow take
the fifth place trophy I don't know
manner in the Wilson house that's what I
need to do oh my gosh but yeah I'm I'm
one of those I got knocked out last
night thanks to Kenyan Drake having a
monster night and so traded him I should
have kept him oh my gosh yeah who'd you
get in that trade I don't even remember
oh yeah love does in fact yeah oh I
needed a white traded him for Cam Newton
because I needed a quarterback yeah okay
it worked out okay by the way that's not
a bad trade I think usually when you guy
who you have no idea what Drake is gonna
grow into but I'm one of those guys that
I had to give myself a pep talk last
night in this morning that life's gonna
be okay yeah did not make the winner's
bracket are you like that when yeah when
when I lose it fantasy and the Seahawks
lose it's a very dark cloud in our
household when the Seahawks lissa stay
out of danwon love it's loose when love
arts and the Seahawks lose yeah you have
a bad day is what you're saying mm-hmm
so what's permanent about rain what do
you got for me here on there it's about
97 minutes I want to say that permanent
is a terrific family comedy then is
being launched on the same day as Star
Wars how's that working for you um
that's not gonna work out very well but
it's okay it's a terrific
it's a terrific comedy Patricia
Arquette's fantastic in it right it's
got it it's very heartwarming it's
family-friendly and quirky and kind of
like Little Miss Sunshine ish right um
it's it's it's terrific
hmm yeah and you should say that there
are there are lightsabers in it too
right I mean there's laser battles
that's right all throughout there's a
certain route at the moon community that
you go and visit yeah and those cute
little furry creatures right no we we
made the movie for about a million
dollars which is which is really like
the leather glove budget on the Star
Wars movie mm-hmm that's what they spent
on the leather gun just leather gloves
alone yeah well it's in theaters new you
this coming weekend you are on star a
Star Trek correct you played you played
the space pirate Harry
from back in the day it's not to be for
you a personal thrill right I was such a
Star Trek geek and Star Wars geek and I
saw no problem being a fan of both of
them and to get to be on the series and
to play an iconic character like Harry
Mudd was it was a dream come true
yeah absolutely what was your favorite
Star Trek episode of all time would you
say um what's my favorite you know I
can't really answer that one but I will
say that the that I showed my son the
tribbles trouble with tribbles the
original one and just the delight on his
face and the giggles the laughter and
the and the the joy and wonder that he
experienced like that's that's that's
pretty great well maybe you should just
think of those moments you know if the
Seahawks should lose and I'll think
about triples and love Earth's should
lose you know what we've got guinea pigs
which triples were based off there you
go as they breed like tribbles there I
go just I can just put my guinea pig
before I let you go to tell me about
your charity work what where people can
go down to looks thanks rich you got
yeah my wife and I do girls education
work in rural Haiti and it's called lead
a Haiti org li de Haiti org and we're
working with over 700 girls in 13
locations with literacy and scholarships
and arts education and it's uh it's it's
a great it's a great adventure then you
fly there and I've seen your photographs
under grandma can I go to three four
times a year
down there we bring our son down and do
work and teaching but most of my work is
fundraising here in the States and
working on board stuff and you know all
the boring stuff well good for you man
come back anytime you want Rainn Wilson
thanks coming on the show permanent is
in theaters this Friday December 15th
with Rainn Wilson and Patricia Arquette
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience